the words were also like i did this research yes not only was this person stealing your report but
they were also claiming to do research they didn't do that's hilarious
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing
all right y'all we've talked about threat locker ring fencing a lot we know how it allows you to
set acls and policies for exactly when an application is allowed to do in your network
but today i'm going to tell you how it does that okay three technologies mini filter drivers
window filtering platform and ex version kernel notification routines many filter drivers are
essentially a hook or callback for um io requests okay so when you're trying to write or read from a
file you can create a hook with those and improve or deny based off of the threat locker acl windows
filtering platform similar situation but for connect bind uh requests right you can say okay hey is this
process allowed to talk to port 443 over there on the internet yes or no approve or deny lastly you've
got ex version kernel notification routines the ex version is important because it allows you to
approve or deny versus just getting a notification from the kernel um and this is specific for um
hooking various native api calls like nt create user process which is what you would use to like spin up
powershell.exe or something like that okay so those three are very useful to threat lockers ring fencing core
technology hope you enjoyed learning how this is implemented check out threat locker if you think
your work could benefit from something like that all right let's go back to the show
what's up hackers we got that this week in bug bounty segment where we do rapid fire news
this week we've got two entries one is uh the bug bounty maturity framework from hacker one which is not
the bug bounty maturity framework we mentioned last week which is from steve hernandez um so don't get
those two confused there's been a lot of chatter in the world right now about um quantifying where you
are if you're a bug bounty program manager and where your program is at how it's performing
um and this is another tool for that so hacker one breaks this up into three maturity tiers baseline
competitive exemplary um and they put this together with feedback from hacker one's advisory board and
technical advisory board hacker advisory board and technical advisory board so really good to see
hopefully we'll see programs starting to look at these frameworks and getting clear steps for
improving their program whether they use the hacker one maturity framework or the bug bounty maturity
framework that we mentioned last week um next up is uh a job posting actually on our job site you can
find that at jobs.ctvv.show and this is a posting for a product security analyst by integrity um so if
you're looking to hop in with the platform it's fully uh you know remote friendly uh so that's great to
see and it's a great way for you to get integrated with the community uh in at large if you're looking for
a position all right that's it let's go to the show hey what's up everyone today i'm here with our guest
valerie we've got a couple of cool things to uh talk about but uh he is a long time hacker and i'm gonna
make him jump straight into a bug before i introduce him but uh yeah so what bug did you bring us
actually when you mentioned that i need to bring something i was like really like shocked because
that came to my desk 30 minutes before the podcast almost and i was like okay like what can i share like
i have the tons of things and usually it's like really interesting things i don't waste my time on
average like findings like medium i usually do something really extreme exciting and yeah that
cannot be duplicated from somebody so the first thing that came to my my mind was the issue when i
discovered that the company so that's the field of the acquisition when the company have the wide scope
range and they're okay if you hack them through the acquired assets and there is a few programs and
hacker one especially where you can do these things in other places you might be really in trouble i would
say so yeah think twice before making this and so i did the the kind of the recon i did the investigation
of what the company is planning to acquire and i did kind of the preparation of the possible acquisition
so i discovered the company itself wasn't acquired yet and it was announced in the news but the legal part
of the acquisition like wasn't happened before um so i did the preparation and i accidentally discovered
i had an issue with the node.js passed traversal to the server like information and i was like okay
like that's interesting i cannot submit this right now and it's kind of like not really exciting finding
because i cannot escalate it to something critical and i was like i just waited with my like notes uh for
the final part of the acquisition process and when it happened before the before the day of the uh finals
day i checked the bug the bug was legit it worked well and i did the screenshots and i was like in the
way of making the screenshots i was like what if i can escalate it to something because somebody can ask me
like what if like what does it mean for us like what does it mean for us as a business like what is the risk
and i usually like to expose the risk immediately like without arguing that's like you know that's a
server side it should be like uh legit it should be rated as a high or the critical i didn't like to
to play this game i just straightforward with the with the business risks so i checked the environment
variables uh self in the rerun and other files where the environment variables could be placed
and i discovered one place where it was some aws credentials and and other interesting stuff so
the next day the acquisition happened and i was like okay let me report this finally because it's kind
of prepared it's working well and when i did the replication of the steps i realized that the server
doesn't work at all like it's completely shut it down and i was like damn like and the the possible
the possible bounty of that story was from 10 to 12 000 i was like damn like the the issue just
burned to the ashes like what can i do with this but i was like kind of lucky and smart at the same time
i checked the screenshot that i made and i checked the credentials that i took from the screenshots and
from the screenshot with this heavily long like aws credentials i replicate to my cli uh and validate
the credentials and the credentials was legit and i was like okay that's like they weren't they weren't
expired yet they wasn't expired they wasn't rotated even it was like the server was like shut it down
it was the credentials for the core system that was was probably like wired from the company itself
and it worked like to the with access to the database to the aws etc i was like okay like as jason
headache says like there is no places where just defining could be like legit for a very long period of
time it could be legit as like as a short term as well so that was like the brilliant example when you
can find something it was like like really working well for a few seconds maybe you did the screenshot and
the rest is like is like nothing happened extra later so i did the validation part i did the screenshots
and the triager asked me like dude like it doesn't work like and i was like you know but the part of the
credential still working and it's still like important to investigate that story fully because that was
exposed that was the evidence of the exposure the credentials work well it is still working i have still
access to the database like you need to do something with this right so um they acknowledged that
facts i would say and yeah the the issue was accepted and paid well like 12 or maybe 10 and a half thousand
yeah and i was like really like amazed of that and i use this as a great evidence uh if somebody asking
me like you know it doesn't work right now but if it was legit before and if the credentials was legit if
the exposure was legit like it doesn't matter i would say um and i even did the article in the medium and
it get it became viral i would say and i just i use this like very very like um hype words in the title
saying like 10k for the vulnerability that doesn't exist um yeah so that was the story um and another
yeah yeah i think i think that that well i just love that that's such a like a
a key example of why you really have to document everything i try to tell new hunters all the time
because a lot of people get frustrated with triage not being able to replicate things or you know
things going down because right now especially there's like some really long triage times and even
if there is fast triage by the time it gets to the program it feels like it's a lot longer i think ai
is impacting that a little bit but a video poc is just like the best thing you can do because one you can
prove it was working two you can obviously pause it frame by frame for any like thing that's exposed or
any data that you've exposed you know you you still have usually the requests and responses inside of
kaido or inside of burp and so yeah i think it's like really important that you document your findings
because like you said those credentials were active and exposed and they have no idea until they go and
do the actual incident response or you know look into who accessed it and how you know whether they
need to rotate it or not um let me add something to that story i think the the new bit that is coming
to this field they didn't know how the process should look like from the company perspective and as a
security engineer on my full-time work i understand this and i learned that's like attack surface the
investigation part what should be investigated and when and how and like i use this knowledge against
other companies i would say um as a backhunter because i knew okay that was critical that was
exposure you need to investigate this you can't deny this so yeah yeah that's true and honestly i mean
you can actually legitimately even just say that in your reports like hey i manage other programs i know how
how this works you all need to dig into this and do a do an incident or do you know do a do a response
into figure out you know was this accessed by external entities how many people had access how
long was it exposed like that sort of thing yeah so um i know that you i told i whenever i mentioned
this you said you uh had several that came to mind do you want to mention one more bug before we move on
yeah yeah the second one is also like nice and i can even reference the previous guests from the podcast
matthias carlson was in the podcast some years ago i think right he just came back from his retirement
and he was in the podcast and he shared kind of cool stuff that is underrated i would say so he he said
when you open the bur and when you work with the with the scope items everything that is in your burp
history might be the scope items as well even if it's not really listed well in the scope surface and
the the scope list and if the the company itself and the program itself is kind of okayish to have
like interesting parts discovered here and there you might work with this broad really attack surface uh
to discover very just useful and interesting parts and stuff so the story happened pretty much the same
with me i did the investigation i did the research uh for one of the company from the hackathon platform and
i i was familiar with the platform with the program i really recognized that they really appreciate my
effort by bringing the attention to the critical things and i was like okay like let me go like deeper like
what if i will do something extra so i did like i processed i don't want to expose the name of the
organization and the the the technical part but i i did the process as a user like i did something as a
user and i realized that in one page there was the terms and conditions link and the link was really
different what i saw from the name of the url that was the link to to some agency i would say and i was
like totally like i'm doing this stuff for that organization and it should in the text itself it's
the text from that organization kind of but the link is from the other domain like that is that is
not really connected from the who is you cannot like differentiate like you can literally differentiate
it it's a different organization and i was like what if this agency work for that company and do something
for them like literally and i did this like with the with the products that they offer uh and i was like
okay let me check this agency slightly without digging too deep without breaking some rules and like
um making me like harmful uh as a hacker uh so i checked i did the basic recon and i discovered the symphony
uh debug mode uh and from the symphony i was able to go deeper to the environment variables with the php info
of that uh application and the php info it was the credentials to something else and i was like hold on
like i'm not really sure that i'm hacking to the right way like what if i'll break the rules and yeah um the
terms of the usage of that service and i checked one more thing before going deeper i checked another
place where the log file was exposed and the log file in another domain of that organization says
like the log file itself was like kind of useless you cannot do anything with this but the log file
literally says how they're working with the organization that i used before they're like doing some kind of
content management i would say uh doing some like upload files etc i was like okay that's legit that
organization connected to the production where i just saw that link so i i checked the credentials
um it it gave me the access to the to the wordpress admin panel where they're doing this management part
for that organization and i was able as a user with these credentials to change the content
of that first organization yeah and i was like okay that's that's like that's kind of dumb but it's
interesting because i was able to change anything with the story that success with the content itself
and i was like what if they do this as well on the main domain because i discovered that from the
organizational one and what if the the main organization have this in the main domain right so i checked
and i found the for the the the path with the with the login with the login to the wordpress and i use
these credentials to get into the main domain of that organization and it worked well so the suppliers
did their work but they did with this that work not really smart enough to use different credentials
for the different environments uh for the different applications and yeah i was able to to jump so far out of
scope to bring the items from the out of scope to the in scope and it was so heavy organization just
immediately like broke the rule broke the application itself stopped the the service changed everything
um but the fun part is like that's legit story when the supplier can hit you hardly like and you should
as an organization you should do your your own due diligence uh before working with this organization
right uh another part uh that is really interesting for me was um that that wordpress admin was on a
very well-known brand and if i will tell you like later after the podcast saying like look i got the
admin access of the wordpress of that organization you might be very surprised saying like no way they have
wordpress on the main domain but the story is they're doing the microservices integration to from the
from the odd domains to the main domain through their proxy and you see like kind of the link but
technically that's a proxy embedding the content from the different domain and from the different like
really like scope of the domains with the applications with the technologies and as i said before like
Matthias Carlsen was kind of smart saying like that's my your your scope items itself by crawling the the
application so that might happen and for me from that story it's kind of the question every time when
the when the triad was saying like look guy uh that's not listed in the scope right but with this
complex situation when everybody might work with the different microservices with integrations with the
proxies how can you like say like if it's legit or not like you can only like yes i think yeah
but yeah that story is really like important to to mention once again like don't go too deep
before like doing something like you should like summarize and think twice before like kind
of breaking the rules i would say yeah yeah no i think the fact that you found that log file is like
hilarious and cool because you basically were able to like know for a fact that they were using this
provider for their you know third-party management of their um of their cms or whatever it was but um
yeah no it also reminds me i had a very very similar finding actually um i was working with eric uh today
is new and he had found like a leaked google doc like google dry or google sheets link that had a whole
bunch of like hard-coded usernames and passwords um for a bunch of drupal websites and it was the same
exact thing a major company had hired uh you know some sort of like content or marketing firm to basically
manage all of their drupal instances and so then they had just put all the username and passwords for all of
those drupal websites which were in scope you know like the the company that we reported this to was
like you know star dot you know example.com and this was a whole bunch of like marketing pages for
that that were on that domain and so it was in scope but basically the third-party marketing company
had exposed all of those credentials and you could just straight up log in and then use the drupal
um there's like a in some drupal instances you can just get rc immediately on the server
and so it was like i don't know it was like it was like rc across a bunch of different sites
and i absolutely think that what you reported was in scope right i mean you could manage the content
for that main thing and i'm not surprised at all that they you were using wordpress under the hood
because i'm sure you see this all the time whenever i'm looking at major companies it feels like 90
of them somehow have like adobe aem that like tied in with a bunch of other microservices on their main
domain it seems like so many companies even though under the hood it's like also a next js app or
something else they're still like all the content seems to like come from like all of the static
resources still somehow route through aem like that's true for linkedin which is like super weird
right it's like a large company you would think they would have their own thing um so it doesn't
surprise me at all that they were using wordpress under the hood no that's a really that's a really cool
finding man appreciate all right so one thing i wanted to mention here was um also do you pronounce
your handle crevetco yeah that's right okay cool yeah so um his handle is crevetco um so on x he's
crevetco valerie and anyways we'll put the links in the show notes but his uh his stats just in case
anybody's wondering just over the last 90 days on hacker one are a 7.0 signal and a 41 impact score
which is in the 98th percentile so like he said he's basically only reporting highs and criticals um
so yeah i had a question do you or do you farm a specific program like do you have some anchor
programs or do you kind of like just look across a bunch of different stuff like what's what's your
game plan when it comes to doing bug bounty because obviously you have a full-time job as a
as a program manager as well yeah um actually the statistics might be greater because the program when i did
this cool stuff just made the pause saying we have too much to to make that's the very big technical
backlog so we are pausing the entire program because kind of me maybe and other hackers that were there
so yeah and i have a few things in my draft uh so when they will come back to the program uh and then
pause this i have something to surprise them um actually actually let me let me comment right
there it feels to me like that's a second indicator of you being very prepared so like um you know if
i'm being honest i think you know all of us have heuristics for things and i think that like my
heuristic for understanding who you are as a hacker the fact that one you were like prepping for the
acquisition and then the fact that here you have you literally have draft reports ready to submit
makes me like see how like um how prepared you are basically like you know what i mean as a hacker
you are optimizing and i think this is really key because like you know in my personal success when i
first got started the only way i was able to find bugs in this like sea of people who are much more
talented was by being like slightly faster than them right the instant i would get a new invite i would
just like hack on it for two hours and like run all the things and try to get a report in because i knew i
wasn't smarter than a lot of the hackers at that point in time and so i knew i had to win by speed
and so it feels like you are you know kind of optimizing in a similar way um and it comes through
like you basically being prepared which is really cool i would say controversial um i'm kind of lazy and
i'm doing my homework uh just to have my time and my like rest time on my sofa so i'm doing this homework
yeah just to save my time in the future uh but that's never ending story i'm working working working
yeah and it might feel like i'm really concentrated and prepared but technically when i'm getting some
results financial results for the year or like statistics results from the reputation score i'm kind of
trying to be chill like usually it happened from the august or from the september like when the all
goals that i put on my desk achieved and i was like okay like let's do some fun stuff like uh riding
snowboard riding the surfboard um anything i want yeah without focusing on security especially
yeah um so let me go back to my question so did you say you do have anchor programs or
how do you handle that like that's kind of the the my like i'm doing this first first of all i'm doing
that part of hacking on that way because i just want to be with the high success rate of each submission
i didn't want to waste my time on the duplicates on the questionable reports where the the the impact
might be in question from the program management side uh i do this specifically uh with the yeah as you
says with the highly critical uh that's the success um when i'm doing this i'm trying to find my passion
i can't like force myself to the specific direction hacking to the coinbase hacking to the something like
really hard programs where everybody was there i would say so i'm trying to find my passion first with
the leaderboards of the private programs okay i got the invitation to the private program that private
program is on the platform for at least three years already let's check who is in the leaderboard okay
the hamster okay justin let's beat that guys with the with the findings with the statistics uh and
that's kind of the part of the motivation from my side how can i like uh stick on that program um
if the program was really old i'm trying to check what the activity statistics was what they're like
really a lot of findings before or they're just wasting the time on the contract paying to the
hacker one without really profitable bucks because that might happen so if i see this i was like okay
that's my time let's make the rock and roll let's surprise the program and that happened a few times
even my friend he worked in one company uh and i got the invitation and the program was old i was like
okay like there is a guy there is a band in leaderboard um let's do some something interesting and i got the
third place i would say uh in their entire leaderboard history and a friend of mine once uh once shared
with me not the private message but the the feedback from the development team when i discovered another
critical findings and i was like okay like the people really amassed of my work and it kind of feel for
me to bring more uh so i'm trying to to work on the programs where i see that appreciation i would say
and when the company even commanding the findings with the human text that in our days it's rare like
usually they just use the predefined answers or ai responses when i see the human interaction i was like
okay like dude like that's amazing like i would i would like to work with you more so i will submit
more um yeah that's kind of the passion and the the biggest part is i want to have attachment to the
well-known brands so i i'm choosing the programs where they connected to the health to the connect
connected to the sport connected to the finance and like making the beer time with my friend i could say
dude like i just had them like without exposing anything i can like sure yeah of course yeah that's
really cool yeah i mean a couple of things there one i definitely agree like when there is a human on
the other side that i respect and like and can tell they like like and respect me like i'm gonna throw
out some random names like roy from john deere and like hugs for bugs from capital one like when i see
those things like i legitimately get way more excited and invested and actually hacking on them i think it's
funny that you uh that you use for motivation like bypassing other top hackers on the leaderboard for
specific privates i think that's a really that's a really like uh cool funny motivation um in fact i think
you messaged me i would love to uh for you to share just real quick what uh motivates you to get into
bug bounty hunting because i think it's cool and just the way that like your little goals have like
stacked up over time yeah that's true yeah the fun part started like with the first submission to the
paypal with my friend and before that submission i did the research for fun like it was not my really like
them and concentration i did this for fun i was like curious about how this stuff working how this iot
device is working how this web application is working when i'm using these web applications and i practice
kind of on the real targets and one day the friend of mine uh mined a lot of submissions critical or the
high with a great payout on the paypal and i was like okay what that dude is doing like i kind of knew him
but not really well let's let's check like who is here like what he's doing like maybe to collaborate
and he he knew me before from my social media activities from medium from other places and he was
like you know dude like i really trust you like what if you can like help me to to make more uh more
stuff on that target that i hope and he shared with me the part of the target that where he mined the
the vulnerability before it was like three vulnerability reports with the cve9 uh on the paypal and i was
like okay like that's interesting let's let me figure out what it is and i realized that when he did the
submission they patched the submission not in the chain of the cve they patched this like with the
with the specific chain that can kind of breaking the cv itself so i found the bypass and we did it again
together nice and my first my first bounty was 6k like i was really amazed like you know i was i would
be curious to know what like most people's are mine was 750. 750 yeah i wasn't really um i might be
happy with the 300 with the 200 but with the 6k i was like holy moly like what is going on and that story
did you have did you have anybody in your life that was like shocked by that like did you were
you young and like told your parents or did you have a girlfriend that you told that was like mind
blown no i was like really like already kind of mature i uh i had i had a wife uh we got a kid and
i was like you know like i just saved uh our rental payments for the next like four months is five
months wow and i was like like kind of that feeling of fresh air like kind of spin that wheel uh and i i
from the time i started constantly spinning this wheel because of the gamification platform i would say
like you see this leaderboard you see this statistic you see the that uh stick um pictures you like okay
like um i was lazy on that month let me find something and each month i'm doing this like for
how many years i think more than six i think all right dude thank you for all of the all of the tips
and all of the like insane uh bugs that you've already shared but now i want to get to like the
main reason we're bringing you on uh for it for our listeners this is actually like really really
interesting to me because uh well first let me let me approach the topic the topic is basically that
valerie had some reports last research stolen through bug bounty and um i'm gonna let him kind
of lay it out here in a minute but i think this is like very very interesting because of the the way
that it happened and you know we've known in the past hey if you submit a vulnerability through hacker
one there's always like a tiny chance that hacker like the hacker one triage that sees it might take it
you know hacker one punishes that and is very um serious about it but there's always a chance
and then also we've seen examples of program managers or triagers for programs taking research
and running with it but this is kind of something that's neither one of those and it's pretty interesting
and so valerie uh you uh actually i must stop calling you valerie i'm gonna start calling your
hacker handle because i always like being called rezo on here so crevetco uh you know you you reported
a bug back in 2023 and it was more of like uh an entirely like new research attack vector that you're
not really willing to share yet but then tell us what happened kind of after that yeah um well i think
it's kind of kind of important to share that it was the attack surface like it was not the vulnerability
it was not the tiny vulnerability because i shared that story with my friend and the friend said like
well like some people might steal your xss attack payload like why don't you like uh care about this
um and but then in that time it was the the attack vector itself and it was harmful attack vector
because before that like it was 2021 i did the research and uh in the 2023 i discovered that i
might do even greater things with the different techniques and with the different technologies and
and the data this would be this would be kind of like if someone found request smuggling
kind of before before someone else did and then was like using it on target it's like a new
vulnerability class kind of yeah that that was definitely the class uh so i did the disclosure
for a few programs just to verify my my theory and how that happened and how impactful it is and i still
have this like classification in my hacker one profile in the private where some money is accumulated to
that classification uh which is kind of interesting uh so i did the verification for 10 maybe reports on the platform
uh discussed that vulnerability not the vulnerability attack vector with one of the top hacker one um hackers
he's i think in the first five um positions in the hacker one leaderboard uh even on those days and even
right now so that's a trusted guy and we discussed with him like about that about the what can happen
and how can we verify how can we submit this but submitting this on that time was kind of hard and
you might be punished quite well like nobody noticed that it's a like it's a the the problem itself not
just you're doing something bad against other organizations um so yeah the times fly i changed from the
period a few places um and i landed in the organization where we do our program management
like we have the program we have the scope we have the applications and i did this research against
our own organization uh just to verify that we are kind of secure and deep like where you work uh i'm in
the semrush and you mentioned before the semrush no no no i'm i'm saying that that's where you did it
that's where you like uh right now this part of the story that's where you saying you tested it internally
yeah yeah yeah it was verified internally so and i even did a few talks uh within the organization
saying like look that's the attack vector uh that is kind of bad and we need to to make some
like protection mechanisms in place and we did this uh i did the education part for the security team for
the for the um in place and we kind of carry this um and yeah after the three years i got the report from
the hacker one and it started with the words and with the links as i did three years ago like like
completely like even like the commas the the the words itself like it's replicated 100 percent and i was
like so just to clarify for the listeners basically kervetko three years ago submit something to like
10 bug bounty platform or sorry 10 bug bounty programs like puts in like 10 reports then literally
like like it was a month ago or two months ago for the program he manages he receives a report that was
word for word his including comma for comma period for period uh the thing that he had basically reported
three years ago yeah and i was really sad because not that the the attack surf that attack vector was
exposed i think it it's well known right now like and some people knew about this some people knew about
how it happening and why it's so but i was sad about that the work i did the words i placed word by
word explaining everything with the link with the reference about that it leaked and the word and the
word the words were also sorry to cut you off the words were also like i did this research yes not only
was this person stealing your report but they were also claiming to do research they didn't do that's
hilarious so i was like kind of okay let's put away out my emotion like let's ask that guy as a program
manager where did you get this like and ask him like dude where did you get this and he like replied to me
saying oh that's that's the chat gpt helped me with this i was like no way like okay let let me try
if my research like three years ago like three years ago leaked to the llm models with the word
by word and if they can give me back this i can't believe you right so i tried i tried 10 times nothing
worked i can't get back the same words as the guy did so it was clearly like he's he got this from
from somewhere and i was really like in a question again saying dude like i i knew that it it's not
chat gpt like share me like the story and he was like did you did you say that at the end or did
you reach out to hacker one first like how how deep how deep did you go questioning the reporter
before you just went to hacker one i didn't try to blame the hacker i didn't try to make my my own
investigation against that guy uh and i knew that that guy might be just the one guy he might found
that somewhere uh and i and i checked his statistics his statistics started like a year and a half so it
it wasn't clear like was he the first one so um i immediately raised the the mediation uh report to
the hacker one saying look like that's the stolen research before and it was never published somewhere
an important part is i never published this in purpose because i was like afraid of magnitude of
the problems that might happen with other organizations and companies if i will share this publicly so yeah
i think that you the way that you talked about it at your work it sounds like it's kind of like not a
super easy fix like you need to come up with some like mitigations or strategies for it right yeah yeah
yeah and if i will just expose this pandora box to everyone yeah i might be just the one the first guy
who will be gonna blame about that problem on all the companies around the world uh i wasn't happy about
this so i keep that as a secret uh so the guy replied to me back saying no no like that's
100 chat gpt i was like dude like that's that's horrible like you're doing horrible things you're
stealing the the word by word report even started with like i'm doing this research like you never did
this like what are you talking about uh so yeah i shared all the things to the hacker one and to my
surprise hacker one did quite well investigation and i think i might say this that they discovered multiple
people use this uh as a template uh they first said that it's a stolen template but it's hard to say that's
just a template it was like the pure research explained well and like somebody who have zero clue
about that might just replicate and get some monies like it's not the template it's kind of research
um yeah so they did investigation and um they found that that might be leaked not from the hacker one triage
team uh but could be leaked from the customers i would say um yeah 100 uh i'm not surprised about that
and could be leaked from the uh collaborators uh who joined the initial report uh because they submit the
duplicate one and that story is kind of kind of shady um and it's difficult to protect your like
intellectual property yeah in that story uh but it gave me some insights about that story as well and
i'm really like curious uh and i'm really happy to share this with you because it might be important to
other hackers like to think twice before making the report so much clearer just to to express someone
just to make some bonuses maybe for the for the very clear report i don't know uh so yeah the the
intellectual property might be exposed from the customers because i saw the organization when the
it was not my organization and it's not mine at that moment but the friend organization was connected with
the slack channel to the hacker one platform so when the researcher submitting the finding it's going to
their slack channel uh and that's that channel was publicly accessible to all employees not just for
the security team and you can't control managers from marketing team you can't control sure like other
people that is have no ideas what it is but they just can copy this right they can think like okay that's
interesting let me share this with my husband or with my friend for example right so you can't really
control this and keep this uh as a secret and yeah the second part is the when the collaborator
joining the initial report uh because he made the submission as a duplicate that collaborator can expose
the chains that you made even if the final report might make quite well but the technique might be
exposed and that's the part that is like extremely important and i think that hackaban should shouldn't
allow program managers and the triagers to allow to join the newcomers to the initial report without
acceptance from the initial hacker if the hacker is okay to share this yeah that's okay if the hacker is
not happy about this to share with everybody um yeah i think it shouldn't work like this like because
right now you can you can put this guy to the main report and he can chase to something that was crucial
for you yeah yeah exactly yeah it's really weird i feel like i've always been on the other side of it
like i i don't know i feel like my reports don't get duped on very much but i've duped on other people's
reports and i'm always frustrated like just let me see the report because then i can verify if this is
a real duplicate or not right like i want to be able to verify myself whether it's a duplicate and
then now all of a sudden after the story i'm like it makes so much sense why they don't just let people
be joined because like all of those people who you know get duped to it one if it if their report
wasn't a duplicate they just got access to your report for no reason and sometimes they are wrong
right so maybe they got added to your report and you lost your intellectual property and they didn't
even submit the same bug it was some other random bug right but then even if they did submit something
similar they still get your full explanation right maybe you're a much better report writer maybe you
have other escalation paths in your report that they didn't have and so anyways now i'm very sympathetic
to that i still think like you said there should be some sort of a way to like request access to that
first report and if the first hacker doesn't care then it's like who cares and i also think that hacker one
and other bug bounty programs should definitely allow the report title to often be like uh verified
because sometimes that'll give you enough information to know if it's like actually a dupe or not
but yeah i i was i was thinking about this and i was uh chatting with ai about just like this
whole situation and i feel like i you know there's like a couple takeaways one is like you said maybe
don't over detail your reports you know like you need to put enough details to replicate it but maybe don't
explain like hey i was doing this research and i found these other things because you know you might be
giving away your thought process or more bugs than you even you know mean to another thing is like run
exploits through like your server instead of third-party services right like set up your own burp collab that
sort of thing then yeah definitely don't disclose like don't automatically add dupe reporters to your thing
and then um one thing i don't know uh if you mentioned this or if it's something that like i wrote down but
uh i think it'd be kind of cool and i think some people do do this but just like have some sort of
like watermark or hidden watermark in your reports like yeah i mentioned this uh as a like as a final
thoughts about a story in the hack one private channel uh saying that's kind of the story why i would
like to keep my secret as a secret without exposing the entire chain of like making the account making
some chains of the bugs to be as a rc um because it's meant to be the code execution so fix this you
shouldn't care about the the part of the chain that i made or like some small part of the chains that is
important for myself um yeah i saw i even saw as a program manager when some people doing the the
variability submission and they giving you the ability to replicate that complex bug through their
own server without exposing the binaries without exposing the the process of making that exploit
um yeah valid um that that up back from the time when i saw this i was like dude like why don't you
share with me this like i need to replicate this and now i was like okay that's the reason like
i i will do the same next um yeah and and over detailing the report it might be like the problem in the
future um and regarding the watermarks like i was such a lucky person to see my report after the three
years word by word but what the guy if was like a bit smart uh just to change the wordings just to change
everything he he found the the the attack vector right but he was smart to to hide this to make as his
own um that dude wasn't smart uh but in that story i think in the in the crucial words maybe or in the
crucial links or the part of the exploit you might put something that can identify you as the owner of that
information maybe putting some mistakes in the word putting the words in the different language where you
can verify it okay google translate please translate this word and it's not translatable because the
word the letter in the middle is like from the different language uh but after all you might verify
that okay that's mine and where did you get it i have no idea what let's figure out so i think that
watermarks kind of the the the important stuff and i even shared this idea with the hack one because
they should secure the reports from triage as well um so yeah yeah the triage is also like the part
i had two cool ways we could do that one is like uh invisible unicode tags like the stuff that you know
is kind of cool for ai and then the other thing is like just zero with characters you could like you
know pepper those in certain places and then the other cool thing about it is like the bug bounty
platforms should be able to like grep across or search across all reports for that string just like
to immediately know if it was used elsewhere you know um i guess it would have to be like a super user
who could do that because there's not very many people with access to every program but um but yeah
that'd be really interesting did they tell you how many other companies they had reported it to or anything
i knew the amount of the hackers that was identified with my template uh and it's more than five um but
less than 10. wow um and i i tried to to push this story forward saying look like what if these guys
might be discovered later in the life hacking event and if they did that shitty things before they
might do these shitty things during the event so i would like to have them like kind of punished saying
like okay they they broke the rules of the code of conduct at least so do something with this because
because of this they will not be invited in the future um as hacker one says like they did this
violation of the code of conduct for the hackers so i'm okay with this and that story might be the
lesson for for those who might have the intellectual property in their own screen uh and they're thinking
about using this well like some days it might be exposed and you will find yourself in a shitty
situation and just measure your like name and the profit that you might gain like that's question
like and i will not do any dirty things against different interesting techniques because i do value my
my name like i don't want to find myself in the trouble in the future yeah yeah that's true you
know it's kind of tough also i'm not standing up for the for the bad guys but i like for the hackers
that did that but you know it's also one of those situations where maybe one or two of those first
people that got access to it said like this is my template as they sent it to the second and third
and fourth and fifth and sixth you know and so they feel like they have permission from the first person
but the first person actually stole it you know it's like man these sort of situations are really tough
yeah that's true but such an irony like seeing my report started with the same words as i did three
years ago and i was like such a joke oh yeah seriously all right dude well uh we can wrap it here
uh i really really appreciate you coming on um did you have any other things that you wanted to mention or
shout out like either your company or your program or your socials or anything that you wanted to uh
mention oh yeah um we do the human validation on the hacker one we don't reply with the buzzwords with
the predefined templates and we do the the good investigation against each of the report uh with
the with the severity evaluation as well and with the business impact so we're not really dumb me as a
hacker i treat other hackers as i want uh to be treated so yeah feel free to submit some bucks on the semrush
program uh that's a public program on a hacker one uh we do pay still quite well uh we are kind of in the
transition of the business transformations soon um you'll find out maybe later in the news uh but so far
we have a program we do our security as as best as possible and yeah if you find something cool and
interesting and critical uh or even if it's outside of the scope or even like at least connected to our
brand and to our organization we do evaluation we don't like uh do that stuff as like other programs might
might make saying like okay we have a scope that's out of scope that's not counted that's informative that's not
counted we really value each report and trying to figure out is it like impactful for the business
do we need to pay for this or not yeah awesome well thank you yeah so go hack on on semrush go follow
krevetko on social it's uh k-r-e-v-e-t-k-o and then his name valerie but you'll find it if you look it up
he's got lots of bug bounty followers so it should pop up for you guys thank you so much for coming on
today brother thank you for the invitation it was a really amazing opportunity i can't still imagine
that you just invited me like who i am i'm just a random hacker uh uh justin said he wanted to have
you on already in the past so uh it's our pleasure appreciate it thank you peace have a nice day
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there